time for this week's pet project and amy
lee joins us from the nspca and she
brought along someone who needs a safe
and good home who do you have amy
hi guys i have stable here and she is
truly
one of the most sensitive souls i have
ever met at the shelter she is
the sweetest and tiniest little
prettiest little pity
she only weighs about 47 pounds she is
so sweet and so she's so shy so we're
really looking for
a loving calm quiet home she does prefer
females a little bit more because just
because she's so timid and so scared
but i really hope that there's you know
the perfect home out there she's
terrified of other dogs and
sadly she's got some some scars on her
legs from a past that we really don't
know too much about
we did get her from another shelter um
and we just want to get her the
the best home that you know will adore
her and spoil her and love her that she
you know that the way that she deserves
um she really doesn't have any medical
um you know she's been here and she's
been great she loves her walks she
really loves to just cuddle
um when she gets scared you know you'll
see her sweet little head kind of
kind of bend down and she kind of shuts
down a little bit so we've been doing
our best to make sure that she's
comfortable and feels secure and we've
just been spoiling her with tons and
tons of love
so if you you know if you have the right
home for her a quiet gentle home
kids 13 plus would be perfect for her
again no other dogs
she just wants to be your cuddle buddy
she just wants to sit on the couch with
you and just be spoiled
oh i think everyone collectively just
went oh she
is adorable sable just needs some love
that's all she needs
if you're interested in adopting a pet
and thank you amy for joining us
go to the nevadaspca.org to go to their
website
or call them at 702-873-7722
las vegas now